the parents of a twelve-year-old girl
who died by suicide are now suing the
school district for what it did not do
to prevent it
Jamie yuccas spoke to the mother about
the call she felt could have saved her
daughter's life I wish I knew she felt
that alone I wish I knew I wish I knew a
lot madison Ogletree was just 12 years
old when she texted a friend about being
bullied and that she was contemplating
suicide did you see anything like this
coming no absolutely not
she was a happy kid she had the biggest
heart in the world
she was so outgoing very outdoorsy in a
lawsuit her mother Morgan Ogletree
alleges that on April 5th
Madison's friend alerted a teacher who
shared the suicide threat with the
principal and vice-principal a counselor
met with Madison and promised to follow
up my husband and I weren't contacted we
didn't even know that she saw the
counselor that according to the lawsuit
violates the Yuba City School District
policy on suicide prevention which
states whenever a staff member suspects
or has knowledge of a student suicidal
intentions the principal or counselor
shall then notify the students parents
or guardians as soon as possible I am an
involved parent and my husband is an
involved parent and we had no idea we
could have talked to her I mean at the
very least we could have made sure that
she understood that she had someone in
her corner seven weeks after the initial
text the lawsuit claims that one or more
of the persons who bullied Madison urged
her to commit suicide as late as May
23rd 2019 that very next day Madison
Ogletree turned in her homework
assignment and hanged herself do you
think the school just blew this off and
didn't think it was a real threat I
honestly do it's a blatant disregard for
rules that were put in place I mean
their very own rules that were put in
place to prevent something like this
from happening is that why you felt like
you had a file lawsuit
absolutely this can't it can't be just
dismissed it can't something
has to change and maybe they didn't
think it was a valid threat but that
wasn't their choice to make
she explicitly said that she wanted to
commit suicide all it takes is a phone
call for CBS this morning Saturday
Jamie yuccas Yuba City California it's
heartbreaking and it's infuriating you
have got to alert parents I have known
parents in a situation they're involved
and they weren't aware because you see
signs and you just don't realize you
need that wake-up call sometimes to pay
attention you saw the signs in that last
picture that last image of her there
were tears in her eyes beneath that
smile your children at 12 and 13 are
going through adolescence they don't
talk to you as much as they once did
they don't share and there the school is
often where is where they do with their
friends and so or a counselor look the
guidelines are in place for a reason it
says if someone says this you tell the
counselor they can't then you tell the
parents parents were never told protocol